US inflation hit a three-decade high in October
2021, rising by 6.2 percent. With little evidence
that inflation is moderating, each monthly
inflation print belies the Federal Reserve's view
that heightened price levels are but a transitory
phenomenon caused by supply chain problems. While
supply-side factors have played a role, the
Fed also has contributed importantly to rising
inflation by its continued pursuit of an ultra-easy
monetary policy. It has done so by its massive
bond purchases and by keeping interest rates at
their zero bound, despite the pick-up in inflation.
And it has done all of this at a time when the
economy is receiving its largest peacetime
budget stimulus on record. Perhaps it's time for
the Federal Reserve to reconsider its monetary
policy stance. If not, it risks causing inflationary
expectations to rise, which could take us further
down the path towards another wage-price spiral.
How has inflation impacted you? Please let us know
in our poll. Also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribefor more research and videos from AEI.